people have always sort of been scared
of new technologies but in the end we
assimilate them and they improve the
quality of our lives hi I'm Zack
Weissmuller with Reason TV we're here
with Jason Silva he's a documentary
filmmaker and media personality in the
mind behind the upcoming documentary
turning into gods
most of us most of the time see the
world through a very small set of
filters he'll be speaking at the
singularity summit in New York City on
October 16 Jason thanks for joining us
yeah thank you for having me big fan of
Reason thanks and turning into Gods the
trailer opens with a quote from Leo
Wilson the famous socio biologist and he
says homo sapiens the first truly free
species is about to decommission natural
selection the force that made us are we
as a species where are we are we
approaching that are we past that as it
coming soon
well Freeman Dyson the physicist has a
wonderful quote he says in the near
future a new generation of artists are
going to be writing genomes with the
fluency that Blake and Byron wrote
verses or with the fluency that
Shakespeare would write sonnets so this
idea that the the new canvas for the
artists is now life itself what kind of
new forms of human creativity human
flourishing are going to come out of
that you know when you consider the fact
that sort of every technology unleashes
a new form of human expression that
didn't exist before which is sort of the
way that I see it you know Kevin Kelley
has talked about how you know the
technology of the instrument the piano
or the technology of musical annotation
allowed Mozart and Beethoven you know to
emerge through that right and so now
that'd be the new sort of palette for
aesthetic design for you know
intelligent design is is is is the
technology of life itself I just think
that that is really exciting and I think
it means that we've crossed a critical
threshold in the sense that like
evolution has become self-aware it has
woken up you know what Carl Sagan says
we were all ready for the cosmos to know
itself I think that he is referring for
the virtue to the moment where we're
actually going to start sort of
tinkering with things and advancing you
know evolution has evolved its own
evolved ability with the arrival of
so we're there I think we're there I
mean when you consider the fact that
we've created more technological change
in a hundred years or we have a crude
more change period than evolution that
in a billion years that exponential
increase points to the fact that like we
may we know craig Venter might have just
created synthetic life a short time ago
but progress happens at an exponential
rate we're going to become masters at
this technology a lot quicker than
people might intuitively believe I mean
Kurzweil has the famous example about
the supercomputer in the 1960s in
Stanford there was 60 million dollars
and half a building in size right and he
says the computer in your smartphone
right your smartphone today is a million
times cheaper a million times smaller
and a thousand times more powerful it's
a billion fold increase in price and
performance that hasn't stopped that
exponential progress is going to
continue and everything that is the
information technology swallowing up
these you know it's it's spilling over
from the electronic into the real right
because biotechnology is now you know
has turned biology into an information
technology so it will be subject to that
same accelerating progress and then with
nanotechnology we're talking about
changing and infusing intelligence into
matter designing with are the constructs
of reality at the nano scale are now
going to be also subject for our
aesthetic design so what are we talking
about rendering our imagination into
existence in real time we're talking
like Inception dreamscapes but in the
real world what do you say to people who
get kind of scared or freaked out by the
stuff this transhumanism we're all going
to merge with the machines that freaks
some people out what do you say it does
no no it's interesting people are always
scared of new technology and and I think
sometimes people who you know where
we're stuck in the reality tunnel of the
present you know usually it's good with
macro thinkers encourage us to get an
aerial view of things so we can see the
big picture but you know when when the
technology of writing like was first
invented like Socrates thought that this
was heresy because it would atrophy
people's memories because now they could
like download their consciousness and
write things down and they wouldn't have
to recall things so people have always
sort of been scared of new technologies
but in the end we assimilate them and
they improve the quality of our lives
you know so many prominent scientists
used to say men would never achieved
flight you know and then of course we
have airplanes now that not just don't
just fly but allow us to
communicate telepathically with the
earth I mean Wi-Fi on a Virgin America
flight means that not only can we fly
but we can be telepathic while we're in
flight
Kurzweil the wonderful futurist talks
about how we are the species that
transcends its boundaries our function
is to sort of expand our sphere of
possibility we've done it from the
moment that we picked us we picked up a
stick and used it to sort of reach a
fruit that was on a really high tree
we've used technology we've used tools
to extend our reach but also to extend
who and what we are metaphorically and
literally you know the naked ape you
know we may be stumbling primates
stumbling flawed primates but when we
work together
we're primates that can fly do you think
there's anything that can stop it
I mean economists Tyler Cowen talks
about the great stagnation which is
basically innovation is reaching kind of
a plateau it's being stopped by the
regulatory state and by a perverse
incentives being set up by governments
do you think that this progress can be
stopped I don't think it can be stopped
I think you know things can be slowed
down but I think it's like a flowing
body of water it'll kind of go around
you know you kind of drive around the
dummies and I also believe that you know
the sort of decentralized nature of
information technology now with the
internet makes it a lot harder to sort
of pull the cord on that kind of
innovation I mean when Steven Johnson
talks about the rise of the coffee shop
and how it led to a simultaneous or the
rise of so much innovation it's because
you put all these smart minds together
in a sort of a small in in terms of
density it's going to lead to that kind
of emergent self-organization you know
just like when atoms come together and
they sort of turn into you know they
lead to have emergent properties but I
think what the Internet does is it
connects all of our minds together and
we sort of transcend the limitations of
time and distance so now we move into a
post geographical world where we can
come together and self organize and have
unexpected relevance and serendipity
based on shared passions not bounded by
the skin bag or the meat space right and
you know amber case the cyborg
anthropologist says every time we make a
telephone call we're actually creating a
techno social wormhole it's
technologically mediated telepathy okay
we are telepathic creatures and you know
and you
I wrote Natural Born cyborgs said that
we should stop thinking of the mental
apparatus as bound by the skin bag
because the reality is the mental
apparatus is a dance between brains
their environments and their
technologies and their tools you know
the extended mind thesis talks about the
fact that our iPhone is not just like
something that like we use as a tool but
it's actually an outsourcing our
cognition storing parts of our memory
just like we have a neocortex or a
frontal lobe the iPhone is part of the
extended amend of I true vien man as
Leonardo drew him today would have an
iPhone in his hand and the iPhone would
have a little diagram that says this
gives us telepathy just like the frontal
lobe or the neocortex give us complex
thought it's a part of who and what we
are someone who's so interested in
escaping your skin bag yes not a it's
not surprising you've made so much of
your career on the Internet
you've been a host on Current TV you
make your own internet documentaries
what is the role of the democratization
of information that has happened with
the internet in in one sense it's easier
to get your stuff out there on the other
since it's such a cacophony so many
voices well you know I think that you
know we it's interesting to draw the
analogy between psychedelics and
computers but you know Timothy Leary
used to say you take psychedelics to get
rid of your mental filters to get rid of
your preconceptions to sort of expand
your sphere of possibility to unbound
you know free your mind right and when
he saw the potential of computers in the
internet he came out in the 90s as a
technological s.d of the 90s you know
not to mention the fact that a lot of
the engineers who invented the personal
computer in the microprocessor who Rican
sieved of of computers of these big von
Neumann centralized things into these
tools that could free individual minds
it could be extension of into individual
minds they were all tripping when they
had those realizations and those aha
moments to begin with what the Dormouse
says that wonderful books it talks about
this but I think that that's what the
computer does today to each and every
one of us I mean these decentralized
information technology extends the reach
of each and every one of us and extends
our ability to sort of create
connections with one another so we all
become like nodes in this like macro
brain and I think that the emergent
properties of self organizations
self-organization that that we find at
other scales of reality will start to
occur at on this scale of
reality and III think that it is it's a
transitionary time and we're competing
with a lot of noise on the internet and
to get heard is very difficult but at
the same time you can sort of like surf
that wave of bliss you know so much
farther you know we have to worry about
like gravity or temperature or distance
it's just kind of like your mind can can
soar through the cosmos in a way just
like with the psychedelics yeah it's
interesting you mentioned psychedelics
because you are someone who there's a
lot of people now calling for
legalization at least of marijuana
there's a growing growing swell
thankfully yeah but you actually go
further and advocate the use of
psychedelics yeah I mean look I think it
should be done in a controlled set and
setting 100% and I will actually tell
you I haven't done strong psychedelics
yet I haven't arrived to the point where
I feel like I'm ready to take that a lot
Joseph Campbell hero's journey right but
marijuana I do think is extremely
beneficial as an entry point into
expanding your sphere of creativity
there was an interesting article in a
psychiatry journal that a Joan Alea
wrote about that looked at divergent
thinking and creativity and it was
talking about the fact that um if
creativity were to be measured by
semantic priming which is the
Association that you might make between
one word or concept and related concepts
so I might tell you you know bird and
then you think of aviation and you think
of flying right those are the semantic
priming like when you throw a pebble in
the water and it causes a ripple
associations right
so he says they did a study where they
gave people marijuana to see if it would
induce a state of semantic priming which
means that it would expand the free
associative capacity of individuals and
therefore increase creativity increase
the your ability to draw a novel
connections between seemingly more
disparate things and it turns out that
yes marijuana and some individuals does
induce the hyper priming so the stoners
were right all along well 100% I mean
the fact that the guys that discovered
the DNA molecule were said to have
tripped on acid isn't that a coincidence
either
but absolutely I think marijuana is a
teacher' plant I think it's one of the
most therapeutically active substances
known to man I mean it since high school
I've been writing about tricycle
newspaper by the legalization of
I wanna I'm convinced that you know it
needs to be completely legalized
completely available to anything not to
mention Abraham Lincoln wasn't the one
who says the prohibition goes beyond the
bounds of Reason because it attempts to
make a crime out of things that are not
crime by legislating a man's appetite
how dare we go into somebody's bedroom
and tell them they can't do that in bed
how tell how dare we tell somebody they
can't smoke a joint you heard it from
Lincoln right Jason thank you very much
for joining us today it was a pleasure
oh man it was absolutely a pleasure yeah
for recent TV I'm Zack Weissmuller